here's four
smart money tips that no one ever wants
to hear according to a financial planner
so this financial planner her name is
misty lynch she's a certified financial
planner and she tells business insider
she goes listen ignoring money advice by
the way this is from a macro perspective
okay
comes at a price
not understanding how money works comes
at a price financial illiteracy
cost americans 415 billion dollars in
2020 wow okay not understanding interest
rates not understanding how much debt
you have not understanding where you
should be investing your money not
understanding just the basic stuff of
budgeting yeah uh has its ramifications
okay so she says there's a part of our
brain that is constantly trying to seek
pleasure avoid pain and take shortcuts
okay so if you heed
no other financial warnings at least
consider these four tips from this lady
called misty lynch no relation to
merrell merrill lynch thank you adam
okay no problem
so here are four tips
from a business insider on money habits
number one you need a budget number two
your parents and your grandparents may
mean well but it doesn't mean they're
right number three taking a risk isn't
always a smart move and number four
sometimes the best thing to do
is nothing at all let's get into this
thing okay so number one we talk about
it all the time
have a budget have a budget have a
budget have a as a budget you know i
always say that the only thing worse
than doing a budget is not doing a
budget right what is that right there
whoa that was uh
keep going okay it's a little glitch in
the matrix a little glitch in the matrix
so anyway budget is is what she says is
the business is the
biggest thing i get it that it's basic
having a budget
a budget is basically your income
minus your expenses what's coming in the
door what's going out the door right
this ain't complicated right right um
you got to have more coming in that's
going out that's just basic stuff right
there all right like what else do you
need to know other than having a yeah we
get it budgeting sucks we get it
budgeting's restrictive we get it
budgeting's strict we get it budgeting's
difficult to maintain we freaking get it
we get it it's annoying budget budget
budget shut up i'm about a budget
but you do need to have a game plan for
your money you do yeah well that's why i
call it within my size six my six
principles of wealth i say that
principle
number one is having a money game plan
yeah i don't like the word budget i
think it's kind of a boring but it's the
same thing
right cash flow baby cash flow how much
is coming in the door what's going out
the door how much did i make this month
how much of my expenses this month
it's not that complicated but most
people don't do it you know what
percentage of america does a budget
10
what 25
3 out of 4 people don't do a freaking
budget you can be as simple as taking a
freaking piece of paper folding in half
what's coming in the door what's going
out door it could be that simple yeah
you could use apps we talked about apps
that you use for you know mint ynab you
need a budget
right uh dave ramsey's got a good budget
freaking do a budget it's not that hard
so it gets a bad rap i get it you know
it's not fun i can't do it i want to do
no we talked about in this thing 50 30
20 rule 50 of your of your income
should go to your needs 30 can go to
your wants 20 it goes to your savings
and you're paying off debt this ain't
that complicated david
i agree man
preachers apply i will i will i will get
up out of this desk right now jump over
there and give you a handshake i'm doing
it right now
um so anyway the whole point of
budgeting is not just for managing your
money but it's also understanding or
illuminating your bad money habits right
so they can be corrected oh [ __ ] i'm
spending
three hundred dollars a [ __ ] month on
these uh
um
what's it called the the subscriptions
yeah oh i didn't even realize i was
playing but oh my god i thought i
cancelled that yeah
all right so a lot of times spending
habits don't really align with the
things that they say that they want to
actually you know do or care about so
um
once you see how much you're spending on
certain things damn i spent 600 bucks on
uber last month what that happened here
i think that's what uh yeah kind of
takes people away from doing it because
they don't want to see how much money
they're actually throwing out it's kind
of gross it's like
ah dude yeah like i spent that much why
did i eat every day last week oh my god
fifteen dollars well
here's what i tell people in their
budget so i can they can walk away with
a little um
tip right here i said this before
uh within your budget you know
understand how much has come in the door
what's your expenses but everyone has
the same big three expenses your housing
your transportation and your food and
beverage how much is your rent how much
is your mortgage how much is your car
how much is your car payment how much is
your car insurance how much is your
taxes i mean your your gas everything
that goes on with your car yeah
transportation food and beverage how
much did you spend for lunch every day
how much is dinner how much is it going
grocery shopping when you got to the
drink when you got to the club that's
your food and beverage if you add that
all up you're 75 of the way with your
budget then people got you know their
cell phone okay cool right they got you
got health insurance cool i get it you
know they got subscriptions cool they
got a gym membership cool but the big
stuff as you're housing your
transportation your food and beverage so
what i do
is i understand that i know how much
money i make a year i know so i know
that if i'm renting i need to be below
this threshold so for instance my rent
is somewhere between 2 500 and 4 grand
depending on where i'm living especially
when i was living in dallas it was a
little bit cheaper but in south florida
that's i know that's my that's my
comfort zone i'm good
um
i know that i'm not because i don't have
a car i don't spend money on all the car
stuff especially when i live downtown
miami i'm spending next i spend like 300
bucks a month max on uber okay i know i
can spend probably a thousand bucks on a
car but i'm saving an extra 700 bucks
just on that and what i do because i
like to go out and have a good time is
i'll spend that additional money that i
would spend typically spending on car
insurance gas taxes tolls whatever the
car
i'll get some dinner i'll buy some
drinks rounded drinks ansas over here
baby i'm good so that's how i budget so
anyway have a game plan for your money
budget like brady i always talk about
that tom brady goes into every game i'm
at tampa bay i'm just going to beat new
orleans saints no i know exactly what
i'm going to do so budget every first of
the month anyway i know we went on a
little bit longer but you need a budget
all right this is again that story from
a financial planner four basic money
tips i know that we just went on a rant
on budgeting all right number two your
parents and your grandparents may mean
well but that doesn't mean they're right
shut up grandma
shut up granny what do you know
you talk back to me one more time
grandpa
threaten to kiss her no it's not that
kind of a thing obviously give your
respect to your grandparents but
basically you know most
grandma shut the f
say another word grandma grandma one
more word out of you and i am putting
you at home
oh your fingers hurt that's great but
now your back's gonna hurt cause you're
pulling landscaping duty grandma
no i'm not talking about that kind of
stuff we love my grandparents i love my
grandma i love my family i get it but
sometimes the advice that they give you
isn't exactly
the right advice all right so according
to lynch again this financial advisor
most people don't want to hear any
advice that contradicts what they've
been told by their parents grandparents
or other respected mentors in their
personal lives right these old farts
they don't know about crypto
they don't know about what's going on
right now they don't know about this new
inflation that we're dealing with they
don't know about salaries and things
that people are dealing with these days
so sometimes you know take the good with
the bad take the old with the new right
now they say make new friends but keep
the old one is silver one is gold sure
actually
um so your grandparents take their
advice in stride okay
um
a lot of things that happened back in
the day even today like electric
vehicles grandma don't know about that
she don't know she don't know about the
push to start she don't know about the
push to start she's know about the
turning point she's getting it she's
getting advice from the bible i get it
now we're getting advice from
black and white there it was
that's what i was waiting on this whole
time give me your best grandpa
impression
sauce cast all i know is dave ramsey
oh dave
um so anyway this lady lynch says
parents and grandparents had a totally
different existence while they probably
mean well it doesn't mean everything
they say makes sense in today's culture
and the economy look the older people in
the country right now they're in their
80s these are called traditionalists
right they are the silent generation the
greatest generation they fought in world
war ii they were fighting the korean war
right yeah they were they were bad they
were badasses yeah right they're amazing
people uh but they don't know about the
newest they don't know about this
internet money they don't know about
nfts they can't tell you about crypto
they don't have all the you know
yeah barely know about index investing
and this index investing would then
become popular to the 90s so maybe they
don't know exactly then you get the
boomers we're basically our parents yeah
right
why iota
um you know they want they want to
protect you they want to kind of give
you the set of
skills or set of information that that
worked for them but that might not work
for you now the millennials the gen z of
the world they're kind of flipping the
script they're doing something different
so again your parents or your
grandparents may mean well but that
doesn't mean that they're right
especially financially okay number three
taking a risk isn't always a smart move
again this is from
uh merrill lynch or not merrill lynch
what do we call her um
misty lynch no relation to merrell she
says on the other hand lynch often has
clients that want her to affirm some of
their riskier financial decisions
uh when they don't even make that much
sense i.e a client basically asked if
she should quit her job to focus on her
side business full-time that was making
no money so she looked at her and said
no no no no no no
make that money save that money work on
your side hustle on the side don't quit
your full-time job until your side
hustle has actually taken off right yeah
okay because at that point it's not even
a side hustle it's just sort of a dream
that you would like to do not paying the
bills right don't forgo your primary
source of income that's paying the bills
and making you money for an idea that
you have work on the idea right let's
say you're working eight ten hours a day
work on the idea of another three four
five hours a day if you love it spend
all night doing it but don't quit your
job to focus on something
that
isn't going to reap any rewards for you
right now that's asking for stress
um
so
is this something that you're from like
you're you like music you're not going
to quit your job to focus on music right
now no there's i mean man yeah there's a
great book called i forget the author
but uh no excuses and there's a part in
that book where it talks about uh time
management people a lot of people say i
can't do uh ex things i don't have time
dude there's so much time in the day
that we waste
where you can allocate those two or
three hours to that dream i mean
i mean a lot of people think i have to
like spend the entire day focusing on
this thing to make it work i have to
quit my job no
elon musk bro spend an hour
compound interest there it is bingo she
also says this often comes up with
people looking to get into riskier
investments right taking on risk isn't
always a smart move we talked about
quitting your job to the side hustle
right here uh they say something like i
want to play the market or i want to get
into this or that crypto or something
like that
but
they still have bills they need to pay
right maybe there's a better option at
work that offers a 401k or you can get a
roth ira or something like that maybe
there's different types of accounts you
should look at
uh you don't need to necessarily take on
all the risk right we talked about a few
episodes i want all the smoke you don't
need all the risks right right so
uh
pay your bills on time before you start
investing in crypto okay last but not
least sometimes
the best thing to do is nothing at all
we talked about warren buffett just say
no just say no now you don't have to do
everything the power of no you like that
so you know we're all gonna you know
have things that happen in our lives
that are gonna take away
um
from your focus right whether that's a
breakup whether it's a new job whether
that's some you know a death in the
family major life shift
it's important in those moments to slow
down right don't make any rash drastic
decisions immediately especially after
big things happen right so take the time
to actually process it so we talk about
um
logic
over emotion so you know anytime someone
says oh i just inherited a hundred grand
or i just won the lottery bro you know
what i recommend they do
nothing for six months don't do anything
keep living your life just live your
life you've been doing it for 20 years
30 years 40 years whatever it is
take six months and just wait for the
emotions right i just want 20 million
dollars i'm buying a 10 million dollar
yacht don't do it bro yeah because you
owe 10 million in taxes oh i forgot
about that yeah no no rash decisions
okay so sometimes the best thing to do
especially when
crazy life changes are happening in your
life are nothing at all yeah nothing at
all what are your thoughts i say p pay
your i mean you should have that
attitude towards paying your debt i mean
i think i mean honestly i would like to
think that most people after winning the
lottery the first thing i think is oh my
god i can pay off my mortgage i can pay
off my car i can pay off that credit i
can buy my mom like i pay off my mom's
house i think that's the the when you
ask people what would you do if you want
the laundry oh i'd pay you know all my
mom's debts all my family's debts so i
think have that urgency for that 100
like go and uh pay off all your debts
and then
chill six months yep and see how to uh
properly handle that i like
paying off debts respect uh anyway these
are these are basic these aren't crazy
this isn't groundbreaking this isn't
groundbreaking but this is the stuff
that you need to implement in your life
yeah okay real quick again
um have a budget we talked about that we
ranted on that bro have a budget most
people don't budget again most people
are most people most people are broke
most people won't take the time out of
their day to listen to something like
this most people are most people and
that's why most people are broke most
people don't do a budget do you do a
budget every single month do you have a
game plan for your money you got that
cash flow coming in or what
uh number two
grandma's not always right i love my
grandma i love my mom but their advice
might not always be right number three
taking on more risk isn't always a smart
move you know maybe when it comes to
investing you can have a little more
risk in your life yeah um
but uh not all the time and number four
sometimes you can say no or do nothing
at all yeah okay 100 there it is talk is
money all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken